hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
high-definition unboxing video and today
we're going to be unboxing the HTC
incredible by Google this is the first
well actually the first Android 2.1
Sense UI smartphone on a verizon
wireless network so we're just gonna go
right ahead and unbox this we'll get a
review later so I'm not gonna go too
deep into this and straight off we see
the really nice device with a 3.7 inch
screen but like I said I'm going to be
reviewing this later and obviously just
going you giving you a quick unboxing
here so you can see it says HTC
incredible and we of course get the
device here looks very nice put this off
to the side and keep going and looks
like we get Verizon and HTC is a little
book of tips hints and shortcuts and wow
that's a really really bright battery
I'm gonna take out the HTC incredibles
1300 milliamp battery and we'll go
through that later we also get in the
Box is a USB charging and syncing cable
and the wall adapter by HTC and that's
it so quite a simple unboxing what I'm
going to do since this video has been so
short is actually go ahead and try to
turn on the phone you know and so with
the battery do all things like that and
give you just a very very quick hardware
tour so without any further ado here's
the device itself zoom in a little bit
this is the device and this is our
battery hopefully has enough charge to
actually do this so go ahead and give
you guys a good look at the phone as we
take it out of the anti-static plastic
here this is a really nice looking phone
as you guys can tell this is a 3.7 inch
wide screen whole Hardware tour will be
coming very soon but I'm gonna go ahead
and try to do here is take off the back
of the phone sorry if I I go a little
bit off camera here but I'm trying to
take off the back here
there we go so we have a bright red of
course bright red in size of the phone
and the HTC battery will slide in just
like that and we can put the HTC cover
back on take this plastic off the eight
megapixel lens on the back a little LED
flash click it all back together
and here we have the Droid Incredible it
just started right up so we'll go ahead
and check out this launch screen this is
just the HTC incredible obviously it
says removed before use this is our
little plastic guy that'll tell us at
the bottom where the buttons are for
home menu back search etc so just ignore
that during the boot logo so this is the
first boot of the Droid Incredible
there's the HTC quietly brilliant and a
Verizon Wireless splash screen bells a
little vibration there the one gigahertz
Snapdragon will definitely help the
spoon vote phone boot up quite quickly
and there we go there we have it there's
Sense UI Android 2.1 and the Droid
Incredible so it looks really nice
already can't wait to get start using
this phone this is obviously one of the
newer phones on the market very smooth
so let's go ahead and give you a
hardware tour as you can see at the top
I just pressed that power button to dim
the screen it's the power and phone lock
button is your two three-and-a-half
millimeter audio jack on the back of the
phone is your eight megapixel lens and
your dual LED flash on the right-hand
side of the phone it's completely blank
on the bottom you have your microphone
port and of course the way to take off
the battery of the phone like I showed
you on the left hand side of the phone
you have your mini USB connector and
your volume up and down rocker and on
the back of the phone also is this crazy
with Google design in the whole of
Transformers red and black theme going
on eight megapixel camera with dual LED
flash and your 3.7 inch capacitive
touchscreen at 854 by 480 very nice
screen so I'll get back to you guys
later with the full review video of the
HTC Droid Incredible until then this has
been mkbhd thank you very much for
watching talk to you guys later peace